>>Joe Malin: Hello and welcome once again
to Android Developer Office Hours.
I'm your moderator, Joe Malin.
With me today from Android Developer Relations
are Reto Meier, world famous author, and next
to me Trevor Johns.
>>Trevor Johns: Hello.
>>Joe: Sorry.
And also three gentlemen from engineering.
From your right to left we have, go ahead.
>>Chet Haase: I don't know where we're supposed
to start.
I'm Chet.
I work on the UI Toolkit Team on graphics
and animation and stuff.
>>Romain Guy: and I'm Romain.
I also work on the UI Toolkit Team on graphics
and animations.
>>Xavier Ducrohet: I work on Developer Tools
and SDK.
>>Joe: Thank you.
Well let's get right to it.
We have some questions in Moderator that we'll
start repeating and give you some answers
if we can.
First one.
Using fragments in an application that reorders
them visually in portrait and landscape.
Is there a best policy to avoid java dot lang
dot illegalstateexception or cursive entry
to execute pending transaction after multiple
rotations in a short interval?
>>Trevor: [laughs] That's a good questions
actually.
I'm not sure.
Uh, do any of you up here know?
No.
OK.
[laughs] Um, yeah, honestly I've never gotten
that error.
So I'm not quite sure or, I mean, I think
the problem here is.
I mean, well, you're probably, you're, uh,
just trying to think.
It, it.
Hm. [laughs] I think the important thing would
be to make sure that you're not performing
fragment transactions right during the rotation.
So, if there's some way that you could avoid
that, I'd probably wanna see your code to
see what exactly you're doing.
Most of the time, this shouldn't happen.
So I'm really curious what in your code you're
doing.
If you happen to be watching live, feel free
to hop on the air via our Hangout.
And we'd love to talk with you a bit more
and figure out what exactly you're doing.
But I think without seeing your code, none
of us have a good answer off the top of our
heads.
>>Joe: Right.
I would agree with that.
Based on what everybody has said so far it's
probably best if you do something like post
part of your code to stack overflow so that
we can see what's going on.
There may be another reason that this is happening.
You can't, I wouldn't just offhand assume
that the problem is because of a change in
orientation.
So go ahead and post something to stack overflow
and we'll take a look at it.
Well, let's move on.
We have a link here that says, launcher icons
should use a distinct silhouette.
If this is desired, its' very difficult to
sell the idea to PMs and designers.
As long as Google apps uses squares with rounded
corners.
Any plans to change these?
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Romain: Well, what apps do use rounded corners?
'Cause I can think of only G plus.
All the standards apps that we ship like Google
Playstore, Gmail, they use the silhouette
icon.
>>Trevor: Yep.
Maps as well.
Google plus is pretty much the only app I
can think of as well that uses the rounded
rectangle.
And in that case that's essentially part of
their logo.
So.
Yeah.
>>Joe: I can comment that this may be that
a confusion about what's in the design guide
versus what we use.
As I remember the design guide has an example
in which there's a sort of three dimensional
aspect to the icon with a dropped shadow.
And we're not using that right now.
So I would say that you should use something
that is distinct, that has a distinct background
so that it'll appear correctly regardless
of what the device background is.
Other than that, I, we probably have to look
more into this.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I mean, generally speaking
the goal should be to try and make your icons
match the system icons.
I'll also add one other thing.
Some device manufactures do change the default
icon themes.
So make sure you're actually looking at the
icon theme as they're distributed with, the
stock version of Android.
So, a good way to do it is just to go and
download the emulator and take a look at what
the icons look like there.
Just so you're not confused by any of the
theming that gets applied by boolean modifications.
>>Joe: Yes.
That's a good point.
OK.
Next question.
Both Dr. Sandler and the Jellybean Overview
say you can add up to three notification actions,
but the API Overview says you can add up to
two.
Which one is correct?
Actually I looked into this just before we
started today and the answer is, three.
You can add up to three icons with text and
intense, that will display when you display
the notification.
>>Chet: Yeah, I would definitely trust Dr.
Sandler 'cause he has a PhD.
[laughter]
>>Joe: Right.
Well, I'm not sure that I trust somebody just
because they have a PhD.
But in addition Dr. Sandler is the person
who actually developed this feature.
So I would say that if he's mistaken, we have
bigger problems.
So yeah, the answer is three.
>> male panelist: Yeah.
That sounds like a doc bug we should fix.
>>Joe: Yeah, I'll have to look into that.
The API Overview is basically something that
says here's what's new in Android 4.1.
I don't think we're saying in anything about
either ICS or Jellybean in the API guide itself
yet.
You know, it happens that I work on that.
So I'll go back in and take a look at that
as well.
>>Trevor: We have a question from Ed Burnett
in the Hangout.
OK.
Go ahead, Ed.
I think you muted it.
>>Joe: Maybe muted
>>Trevor: Or I've muted it.
Let's try again.
>>Ed: Can you hear me now?
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: Mm-hm.
>>Ed: OK, so I have a program which uses JNI.
And, you know it works fine on Gingerbread,
Honeycomb and Ice Cream Sandwich.
But on Jellybean I get an error that I put
in the Moderator.
Says "attempt to use stale local reference."
And I'd like your advice on how to debug that.
>>Trevor: Alright, sorry.
So what exactly, so what are you doing when
you get this error, one more time?
>>Ed: I'm making a call to a native function.
>>Trevor: Humm.
Um.
So.
Ed, does it occur all the time or is it only
under certain conditions?
>>Ed: It occurs all the time.
On Jellybean.
>>Trevor: Only on Jellybean?
Um, that's interesting.
[laughs] Unfortunately I don't have too much
experience using the NDK myself.
Most of the work I do is you know, using,
is entirely in the Java language.
So, I can't, I'm not sure that I'm probably
the best person to ask.
But I'm not sure we have any NDK experts with
us right now who could actually answer that.
>>Romain: Actually, this kind of error looks
like what happens when you, goes from JNI
codes or from native codes you can grab references
to the data that is on the data heap.
And if you don't do it properly for instance,
if you grab a reference and you don't release
it, you might run into that kind of issues.
I know that we had a bunch of applications
that were not using JNI properly, so there's
this feature that you can use to check JNI.
I don't know how to enable it.
I think it's in Developer Settings or maybe
the [indistinct] option.
But it definitely sounds like you're trying
to access data improperly.
Maybe you kept reference on the native side
longer than you should have.
But it's hard to say without seeing code or
anything like that.
>>Ed: That's what I figured and I did enable
"check JNI".
Uh, so, it didn't really any extra information.
>>Romain: So if you can post the question
somewhere on stack overflow, or firebug, maybe
we can route that to the data guys.
And they might be able to tell you, if you're
doing something wrong or maybe there's a bug.
But I know that we have tons of JNI code in
the platform and we have not seen this error,
so and I don't believe we have changed many
things with JNI.
So yeah, show us your code and we'll try to
figure it out.
>>Ed: OK.
>>Joe: OK.
Thank you, Romain.
Our next question is "What is the best way
to play short endgame sounds.
Soundpool crashes on dual core phones.
Media player has 200 millisecond plus delays.
Open SL requires SPK9+.
That leaves Audio Track.
Are there any examples for this at API with
static sounds?"
>>Trevor: Alright, I can take that one.
First off, a bit of a clarification.
Soundpool does not crash on all dual core
phones.
It crashes on a subset of dual core phones,
which are running Gingerbread.
So not all dual core phones running Gingerbread.
Just some of them.
Unfortunately this is a bug in the way Gingerbread
was ported to run on dual core devices.
Unfortunately there's not really a good solution
I can recommend.
Unfortunately Audio Track will, if you actually
try and use that you'll find it has the exact
same bug.
So, the work-around here is really, yeah,
the best case is to try and encourage your
users to upgrade to Ice Cream Sandwich on
those devices.
I believe specifically this is an issue on
Samsung Galaxy S2 devices.
And unfortunately upgrading to Ice cream Sandwich
on those I'm told does require updating UPA
USB cable which also makes it a bit difficult
for them to actually update.
But if they're on Gingerbread, probably the,
if you do insist on trying to get this to
work, pretty much the only option available
to you is to write your own mixer as a native
library.
Which admittedly is quite a bit of work.
So, most likely on those devices, if you're,
if you don't feel confident or you don't have
time to go and do that level of work, would
be to go and detect when you're on those,
that specific subset of devices and display
dialog saying "unfortunately this app is not
compatible with your device, please contact
the manufacturer regarding any former updates."
Unfortunately that's really the best answer
we can give you.
[feedback]
>>Joe: OK
>>Reto: OK.
We have another question on the Hangout from
Pieter.
>>Joe: Great.
>>Reto: about fragments.
>>Joe: Fire away.
>>Joe: Hello, can you hear us.
>>[Pedro]: So, are you hearing me OK?
>>Trevor: Yes.
>>Joe: Mm-hmm.
>>[Pedro]: I'm having a little, jumps, OK.
So I have an application that has like a dashboard.
With some buttons that have a lot of information.
So the
[feedback]
UI is kind of complicated.
The fragment that kept the UI logic and kept
it really tight.
So each time the application rotates, in portrait
it has four buttons.
But in landscape it only presents three for
each screen.
So each time I rotate, I have to remove the
fragments and re-add them.
So the problem that I'm having is that if
I rotate really quickly, from portrait to
landscape, and all that, [ inaudible] crash,
that I actually, because I read in the documentation
that the removal of fragments its operation.
So, I didn't, I tried to execute that transaction
to be sure that all the pinging transactions
of adding or removing fragments are done.
But the [inaudible], means so little time.
So I don't know what the best policy, you
have have cross that problem already, better.
So any suggestion is welcome.
>>Trevor: OK.
Do one of you have a good suggestion for how
to handle this? [laughs] No?
Alright.
Yeah, I think probably we need to go and actually
run this by somebody else on our team to have
them take a detailed look at your code.
If you wanna go ahead and post a code snippet
of the code that handles your fragment transaction,
onto stack overflow, and then just post it
as a comment on the G plus post, we can go
and take a look at that after the show and
try and get your answer.
Yeah, unfortunately nobody here on the set
right now knows the answer but I'm sure we
can find one for you.
>>Pieter: OK.
Thank you.
>>Trevor: you're welcome.
>>Joe: Thank you.
OK, let's go back to Moderator unless we've
got other live questions?
Nope.
Go back to Moderator.
"Is there a way to integrate an app into the
new radial menu introduced for Google Now?"
>>Reto: No.
>>Trevor: [laughs] At least not without modifying
the source code for the short system.
But as an app developer, no.
>>Joe: OK.
Next question I have is "Jellybean boasts
that view stub is remotable.
Does this mean that a non-remotable view can
be lazy inflated into this placeholder?"
>>Reto: No.
>>Trevor: [laughs] I mean to go into a bit
more detail, you know remote views have a
bit of restriction as to what they can do.
And so just thinking about this for a second,
if you could place a regular view inside of
a remotable view stub, that's not remotable,
you could probably do a lot of things that
you shouldn't be able to do inside a remote
feeder.
So just from that standpoint it doesn't make
sense to be able to do that.
>>Joe: OK.
Thank you.
>>male off mic : Loophole.
>>Joe: Next question.
[laughs] Sorry, that loophole is closed.
Next question from Moderator.
"Expandable notifications currently have a
fairly large discoverability issue.
Is there a way to make them, make it more
visible that the notification is expandable?
And is it a way to expand it while using the
phone one handed?
That is, not using multi touch?"
>>Chet: Actually, don't they auto expand when
they become the top notification?
That's part of the discoverability.
>>Trevor: Right.
So yes.
The system does automatically expand them.
But the ones that are closed, I mean, if you
really wanted to go and give somebody a visual
cue you could go and add some small text there
saying "Drag to expand."
I wouldn't recommend doing that because none
of the system apps do it which means your
app's gonna feel out of place.
And generally speaking you should try and
make your apps blend in with the style that's
provided by the system apps.
So, given that none of our apps actually go
and provide any additional clues behind, aside
from what the notification floor already does
I wouldn't do anything extra.
I'm also not aware of any way to go and manually
expand them without using multitouch.
But again, the system will automatically expand
them under certain circumstances.
>>Joe: thank you.
>>Trevor: And of course you can always tap
on them, too, if you want to actually open
them.
>>Joe: Right.
Yeah.
I would say that probably the best thing is
to assume that, in most cases, the user's
gonna wanna tap on the notification and actually
go to the application that was responsible
for issuing it to begin with.
That's what users expect.
There's certainly a lot of information now
that became from looking at notifications.
In the current releases.
But still we wanna encourage users to, we
wanna encourage you to have your users go
back to the application to get more information.
That's the best way of handling it with an
app.
I think.
Next question.
"Regarding bitmap dot recycle.
Recently I have noticed heap memory corruption
error occurs.
Is it true that in ICS that we should not
be calling bitmap dot recycle?
I saw this entry but no other documentation."
And then there's a link to stack overflow.
>>Romain: No, it's not true that you should
not call bitmap dot recycle.
you can call it.
But actually as of Honeycomb, so Android 3.0,
calling bitmap dot recycle will not do much.
It will simply set an internal byte rate to
null on the dalvik side.
So it's gonna help a little bit to reclaim
the memory faster as soon as the GC can do
it.
But it's not gonna make a big difference.
So if you're running into issues because of
bitmap dot recycle you can avoid calling it.
It's not going to do anything bad to your
application.
But it's perfectly safe to call it.
Now, I don't know why you're wanting it to
crash when calling bitmap dot recycle.
I'm sure there was some sort of a bug in the
ICS.
And if you have a repro case or you can Firebug,
we'll take a look at it and see what's going
on and make sure that it doesn't happen in
Jellybean or future versions of Android.
And I think there was a follow up to the question,
asking how you can avoid out of memory errors.
So what we've done in Android 3.0 is we added
a new feature in bitmapfactory dot options.
where you can reuse bitmaps.
So you already have a bitmap already in memory.
You can pass it to the bitmap factory so it's
reused.
So we'll reuse the allocated memory.
And you can pre-allocate your bitmaps ahead
of time.
And reuse them as you go so that you don't,
you don't need more memory when you're on
your app.
>>Joe: Thank you, Romain.
Next.
>>Reto: There's a couple of questions from
people in noisy environments on the hangout.
So I'm going to read them out to you.
>>Joe: Please.
>>Reto: This is from Anush Goral.
He says "Is there a way to add the Google
Maps API to the Intel Exit Six Android Emulator?
And I don't want to build a system image from
scratch as mentioned in the stack overflow
question."
>>Xavier: So you can't really do that yourself
anyway.
We do plan on doing it at some point.
We just haven't had time yet.
But it's high on our priority list.
>>Reto: Excellent.
Thank you.
And I have another question from, we can scroll
up here.
From Mark, who says "On Windows XP", and he
apologizes for that knowingly, "Is it possible
to run NTP mode while USB debugging is turned
on, when the next server running Android running
4.1.1?"
>>Romain: Can you repeat the question?
>>Reto: I can repeat the question.
Is it possible to run NTP mode.
Uh.
Oops.
>>Joe: NTP.
>>Romain: So NTP at the same time as you're
doing debugging?
>>Reto: that is correct.
>>Romain: It should work 'cause that's what
happens every time I plug in my device on
my desk computer.
>>Xavier: Windows XP.
>>Romain: on Windows XP?
Uh, I don't, do you know about?
Sure.
>>Reto: I've never tried it on XP either.
So.
I know it works on the Mac, but.
>>Romain: Yeah, it works on the Mac.
It works on Linux, I presume
[laughter]
>>Joe: it works on Linux, You just need to
install some stuff.
>>Romain: OK.
So it works on the Linux, works on Mac, don't
know about Windows XP.
We should try it.
Do we have a Windows XP Machine?
>>Xavier: [inaudible]
>>Romain: OK.
>>Reto: We should be able to dig one up somewhere.
>>Joe: Any others?
OK.
Let's go back to Moderator.
"How can I expand the collapse notification
from Jellybean in the emulator?
Is there a simpler way other than tethering
the device to the emulator to send those multitouch
gestures?"
>>Xavier: No. there's no way right now to
emulate multitouch without that.
>>Chet: Two mice?
>>Xavier: Two mice won't work on all OS.
I think it works on some, but not all of them.
Yeah, we don't really have a solution for
that right now?
>>Trevor: Can you do multitouch via Monkey?
>>Romain: [inaudible]
>>Xavier: I guess you could.
>>Trevor: Yeah, so you can probably run a
script to do it.
Um.
I can't remember what the exact commands are
off the top of my head, but if you take a
look at the documentation for Monkey Runner
on the Android Dev site.
You'll see that you can basically send program,
mouse gestures, key events, things like that.
And then you can use that to go and write
a little script that generates your multitouch
events for you.
>>Joe: OK.
Next question.
"How can one load data on fragments, not creating
them, in a view pager when changing pages,
and avoid destroying the fragments.
Like lazy-loading the fragments data."
>>Trevor: [laughs] Silence.
Um.
>>Joe: We've stumped the panel.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Um.
That's a good question.
I mean there is a [indistinct] then that gets
called when the fragment comes visible, right?
So you could go and try and do it there.
Just listen for when your fragment's actually
on the screen.
>>Trevor: That's probably the best way to
do it.
Yeah.
>>Joe: [sighs]
>>Reto: I have a question this time from Trevor
Solomon on the Android Developers stream.
And he asks, or he says he's pretty new to
Android Development and would like to avoid
using Eclipse, due to the many quirks it has.
Strange, I've never heard that before.
Instead, he's learned about IntelliJ.
However, version 11 does not have a UI designer.
Are there any third party external tools to
help with your UI design.
Preferably free or hobbyist levels.
>>Xavier: Not that I know.
At least not ones that are really go.
IntelliJ 12 will have a UI designer though.
So there is a think a preview version of it.
I don't know how stable it is.
But I think you can download it and try it.
>>Chet: They were showing it at IO.
>>Xavier: Yeah, they were showing it.
But I don't know if it's completely finished
and polished.
It's probably still buggy.
I don't know when it's supposed to be released
and
>>Chet: You could also not use a designer.
>>Xavier: And you could also not use a designer,
yes.
>>Trevor: and it does UI preview.
So if you're comfortable editing XML and you
should be because at some level you probably
will have to edit some XML, you can at least
display what your changes are, even though
you can't drag and drop things around.
>>Joe: OK.
Any other comments?
At an IO session a new version of the support
library was discussed.
That would have a support for the action bar.
Is there a general estimate when this will
be released?
>>Trevor: I can take that one and the answer
is, soon.
I don't wanna get more specific than that.
But hopefully sometime in the near future.
>>Joe: OK.
In the IO session and then there's a link,
Reto talks about dynamically adjusting periodic
transfers and batching transfers.
I'm wondering how his examples can be applied
to the sync adapter.
Like, can I get it to piggyback on a time
sensitive transfer?
Reto, do you wanna answer that one?
>>Reto: Uh.
Let's see, if I'm very lucky this camera will
be pointing at me.
No. let me try again.
Point it at the camera.
>>Chet: I can always tell the audience what
you look like.
>>Reto: That could work.
>>Chet: Wooooo.
Wow was that fancy.
>>Reto: That was fancy, and would have worked.
To go to the site, I don't really have the
answer.
At least not a good one.
I'm not aware of a way that you can piggy
back on top of sync adapter.
So you can trigger the sync adapter to do
a refresh if I'm not mistaken.
So you would probably be wanting to do that.
At the same time as any other, as a way to
bundle those sync adapter updates with any
time scan sort of transfers that you wanna
do within your application.
But I'm not sure of away you can do it the
other way around.
So listen for a sync adapter update and piggy
back the rest of your updates that way.
Does anyone else have any insight there?
>>Joe: It's kind of, my feeling is that it's
kind of at cross purposes to the whole idea
of sync adapter.
Because sync adapter is supposed to control
a lot of that stuff for you for things where
you don't have something that's really that
time sensitive.
On sync adapters, in a certain extent, takes
over all of the stuff that you normally have
to write to figure out when to do something.
Check to see if there's a connectivity, etcetera.
And it's for things that you are willing to
allow on the background.
On a periodic basis.
But not necessarily immediately.
And unfortunately if you've got something
that's really time sensitive, you probably
have to step in and do the handling of the
transfer yourself.
>>Reto: Quick follow up as well from Trevor
who says "Thank you for the answer."
For what it's worth, he's comfortable with
XML but that doesn't necessarily mean that
it's fun either.
>>Trevor: Oh no.
I totally agree.
[laughs]
>>Reto: He'd also like to point out that it'd
be cool if Google released some sort of UI
toolkit to make it easier.
>>Xavier: What kind of toolkit is he talking
about?
>>Reto: That's a good question.
I will ask him and get back to you.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Super.
Um, Let's move on.
Why doesn't Listview support drag and drop
reordering of its items.
Can you consider adding support for this in
the support library?
All the current third party implementations
feel very janky and subpar.
>>Romain: There is currently no plan to add
it to add this feature to the support library
or in listview.
Mostly because it's not a feature that many
apps need.
We have an implementation in our source library
that you can use.
I think it's the music application.
And frankly, it's not high on the list of
priority of things that we have to do.
Our engineers are pretty busy at the moment.
>>Joe: OK.
Alright.
Next question.
"Is it acceptable to wrap SQ like open helpers
as a singleton object as long as the context
being used is the application context?"
>>Trevor: So I think that's probably OK.
I definitely wouldn't do it with the activity
context, 'cause your activity can get destroyed.
But if you use the application context though
you're most likely going to be OK.
The only thing that you could run into is
if somehow the application context becomes
invalid but your process doesn't get destroyed.
Which shouldn't happen normally.
But yeah.
That can't happen, right?
>>Romain: I don't think so.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
So you're probably OK.
>>Joe: Alright.
[pause] "Lock canvas call causing a DQ buffer
fail error.
Got around it by introducing a 20 millisecond
sleep on resume coming from home launcher
screen.
Question, do we need to worry about DQ buffers
or is this just a freak OEM error?"
>>Romain: You should never have to worry about
DQ buffers.
You shouldn't have to know that it's there.
You shouldn't need to understand what it does.
So without, I will have to look more about,
at your error and your code to understand
what's going on.
Let's see, it's in surface texture, yeah,
you don't have code in stack overflow.
Oh, there is code in the stack overflow.
So you're doing that on the surface view apparently.
Um, yeah, we have to look into more in details,
but it's not something you should have to
worry about normally.
It's too buggy.
There are bugs.
[laughter]
>>Joe: Great.
Thank you Romain.
>>Reto: I've got a follow up from Trevor.
In response to what kind of toolkit is he
after.
He said "A toolkit is a UI tool that would
generate and or modify the XML.
Similar to visual studios, [ indistinct] designer
for WPF/similar applications and metro UI
applications in Win Et.
>>Xavier: Well that's exactly what we have
in Eclipse.
Of course, you don't like Eclipse.
So, I don't know what we can do for you.
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Xavier: I mean, our goal is to make it better.
More usable.
How we're going to get past people who don't
like Eclipse, that's another question and
we don't have anything to say at the moment.
>>Joe: OK.
"Does the use of listview provide any benefits
performance or otherwise over a single column
grid view?"
>>Romain: There would be, slight performance
benefits to it because there's, listview is
less work to do.
And also listview is much better and hanging
things like input fields, focus, items of
different types.
Items of different heights.
I mean, gridview, really you should not use
gridview if you're doing a single column and
that's what listview is for.
>>Joe: Alright.
Good.
Excellent.
>>Joe: "This is a more userland question but
it drives me nuts."
Alright.
"I have no clue what I keep doing, but I get
a choice intent Drive or Gmail, when I select
Drive, it goes boom.
When I select Gmail it asks me who to mail
an email a bug report to.
WTF?"
Which I won't translate.
>>Trevor: [laughs] Alright.
So that one is, I assume you're on a, doesn't
say here but I assume he's probably using
a Galaxy Nexus.
Many of the, what you're seeing here most
likely is a debug feature that gets activated
when you push volume up, volume down and power
all at the same time.
And that's equivalent to running a debug report.
But rather than sending the bug report date
off via usb, it creates a file and then sends
off a share intent asking what devices would
like to receive it.
Which, would likely be Gmail or Drive and
possibly anything else he installed that can
handle attachments.
So, the short answer, if it, you know, don't
do that.
Don't push volume up, volume down, and power
at the same time.
If you are using another device, these, the
sequence of keys you have to press does get
changed depending on what keys are available
on the device, right?
I, you know, back in Galaxy, or in the Nexus
1 day, I think it might have involved the
trackball.
I can't remember.
But yeah, in, that sequence of keys, unfortunately,
is a little bit easy to press.
So you're not the first one who has asked
me that.
That being said, if you, it's harmless.
It's just a debug thought that gets generated.
So you know, if you just hit back, the, no
harm done.
If you send it, no harm done.
It's just an attachment.
Then whoever does receive it will get to see
your system log, so you might not want to
send it to random strangers.
>>Joe: right.
And it happens to me on the fairly often.
It just depends on what your tolerance level
is for that.
So.
>>Reto: I have a question from Mauritz Post
on the G plus stream.
He has a question regarding lint.
Should Lint be able to dish up errors if an
application references at android colon attributes
that are introduced after the minimal SDK
version?
>>Xavier: So, Lint, I don't think we do any
check of that sort at the moment.
The issue is that it's perfectly valid to
actually reference some attributes that on
higher than your particular version.
It's just that on lower API level, the application
will just ignore them.
And application running on a version where,
that actually exits, then it would be used.
So at least you should probably put a warning.
But then if you actually want to do that,
you would have to have better was of ignoring
that warning, there are attributes.
But we'll see what we can do.
It's a good idea.
>>Joe: OK.
Great.
Next question.
"There seems to be a bit of overlap between
the upcoming Google Play services library
and account manager.
Has the latter been, from a practical point
of view, deprecated?
If not, can you give any insight on the use
cases where one should be picked over the
other?"
>>Trevor: OK.
[laughs] So, account manager has not been
deprecated.
As for the rationale as to why Google Play
services is not using account manager, if
I remember correctly there were some features
that they wanted to introduce that weren't
compatible with the API service that account
manager exposes.
And so because of that they decided to do
it as a separate library.
As a application developer, if you're creating
your own account provider, I would definitely
use account manager whenever possible.
In fact I think we still will be using account
manager even internally just because we have
to go and keep track of the Google account
you register on your phone.
I think Google Play services just drops that.
As a, an API consumer.
If you're writing your own Android app that
just needs to go and access an account, you
know, decide, basically you have to look at
the API when it's published and determine
which one has the features you need.
If account manager does everything you need
to do, then you're fine.
If you wanna use the new features to get introduced
as part of the Google Play services, then
you know, of course you'll have to use that.
It's really just a matter of what it is you
want.
>>Joe: OK.
Any other comments?
>>Reto: So I have a question from Chris Hall
in the Hangout, who asks "What is the best
way to implement landscape to portrait switching?"
>>Trevor: Rotate your phone?
[laughs]
>>Joe: I'm assuming that, well, that's an
interesting question because I'm not sure
what he's trying to do.
>>Reto: So I'm gonna ask Chris if he can give
us a little bit more data as to what you mean
by implementing landscape to portrait switching.
In that, normally this would just happen by
default.
So I guess we wanna know what is the specific
use case that we're trying to implement.
>>Joe: While we're doing that, let's move
to the next question.
It should be pretty easy to answer.
"I thought I'd mention this, the API reference
docs on developer dot Android dot com are
pretty much unusable on a tablet or phone.
I was wondering if this could be fixed for
those of us who are curious about the AP stuff
as, API stuff as light reading.
>>Romain: So here's the good news, on Jellybean,
we just tried with the standard browser it
works really well.
>>Trevor: Yeah, there is one catch and it
is if you're on a phone, I don't think it's
so much a tablet issue but it just a screen
size issue.
If you are on a phone, the video part's a
bit small compared to how the, the size at
which the docs are easily readable.
It's a known bug with the docs.
In fact, I filed it the moment the docs launched.
So, it s something that I think we wanna go
and address.
It just didn't make the cut for the first
release of the site redesign.
So we'll probably get there eventually.
In the mean time, sorry about that.
I will add also, if somebody feels really
adventurous, and wants to write a Android
API viewer that runs as a native app, I'd
totally love you for it.
[laughs] All the docs actually that we publish
as part of the developer dot Android dot com
site are actually checked into the open source
tree.
I believe most of them are in framework space
docs html.
So if you really wanted you could actually
go and extract everything there, make your
own nice pretty doc viewer that runs natively.
But if nobody gets around to that, we'll eventually
fix the html site.
And I'm not even sure fix is the right word.
We will improve the site to go and have a
more responsive layout.
>>Joe: it's a great question.
I don't personally, I'm a technical writer
for Android developer relations.
And I don't consider reading the API reference
necessarily as light reading.
But it's an excellent question and I'll take
it back to our team to take a look into more.
As far as I know, all the documentation is
in frameworks based docs html.
Certainly all the API reference docs are there.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
>>Joe: and so if you wanted to write, or a
doc with a, to handle that, it would be fine.
I can't offhand remember where our existing
doclet resides.
And, ahhh, so, unfortunately I can't remember
that.
But it certainly
>>Trevor: Actually, I will say, the API reference
I think.
That's actually generated by a Droid doc,
right?
>>Joe: it's generate, well,
>>Trevor: [unintelligible]
>>Joe: it's generated by Droid doc.
Which is a bunch of things that include doclet
functionality.
So.
>>Trevor: Right.
But yeah.
So part of the API references are auto generated.
>>Joe: Right.
>>Trevor: So watch out for that.
>>Joe: Yeah.
You will have to consider the fact that we
auto generate them from the code.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
If you do wanna play around with this, just
run "make offline SDK docs" as the target.
And that'll run through the whole doc building
process and you can play around with it.
>>Joe: Right.
OK?
>>Reto: OK, we have a question from, let me
see, who was he?
From Joram in the Hangout.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Joram: Yeah, I have a quick question about
portrait nomenclature and stuff.
I mean, the, if you proof the word performance
in the system, however, if you want to load
images while scrolling there is still some
jank.
I actually analyzed it with sys trace, and
it seems that process called "image cache"
sucks up all the [ indistinct ] cycles and
the other thread, the other process blocks
in there.
So, why is that exactly, is that a boss problem?
Or it happened on my on the Galaxy Nexus.
>>Romain: What is image cache?
What application on what device?
>>Joram: It's a Galaxy Nexus running Jellybean
stock.
And, basically some frames get dropped off
if you want to try to load an image while
scrolling.
In the background [inaudible]
>>Romain: In what application?
>>Joram: It happens in all applications.
Specifically, with the Google plus set, for
example.
>>Romain: Well, so yes.
I mean Google plus, we knew there was a fluency
issues and people are working on it to fix
them.
It's just a problem with the app.
There's nothing wrong with the system or anything.
If the app is blocking the, there's nothing
we can do about it.
>>Joram: So, a development rich app.
It happens, I mean it happens on YouTube,
in my own apps, on Google plus, every time
you try to load an image in the background
thread, then it blocks the directory thread.
>>Romain: No, it won't unless you are blocking
the rendering thread by doing something else
or waiting on another thread.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I did some demo of this for
Google IO.
Yeah, if you're loading all of your images
you know say in the background thread.
And you're really absolutely sure that you're
not doing any heavy lifting as part of your
UI thread, at least as far as my eyes could
tell there wasn't any jank.
[laughter]
>>Trevor: it's possible there's a common pattern
being used that, [laughs] Wow there's some
good noise on the Hangout.
It's possible there's a common pattern a developer
is using that just happens to introduce jank
frequently.
But as far as I can tell I haven't noticed
anything wrong with the system itself but
then again, it's entirely possible you're
seeing something we missed.
You know, if you wanna, like we say record
a video or something and send that to us.
We can always take a look at it.
But at least as far as our experience has
been we haven't seen this.
I'd love to see some more details as to what
you're saying.
>>Joram: I posted the sys trace, sys trace
to html.
And here you can clearly see that the process
called "image cache" sucks up the CPO cycles
and the rendering process doesn't get the
CPO cycle.
So it might be a scheduling problem or--
>>Romain: It could be a scheduling problem.
It could be many other things.
It could be the, the image cache whatever
that is 'cause that's not part of the framework.
Maybe reading something after the file system
and the rendering thread for whatever reason
is trying to access the file system as well.
So the, one of them is blocked on the other
one.
I mean there can be many, many different reasons.
>>Joram: OK
>>Romain: And I don't think there's one explanation
for all the issues.
But you know, in Jellybean we've improved
performance throughout the system.
But we're still working on that.
So we'll definitely look into that and I know
that the G plus guys are looking into those
problems already.
>>Joram: OK.
Thank you.
>>Joe: yeah, I think a key thing here as far
as I can hear is that this image cache process
that he's talking about is not part of the
system framework.
So it's important to figure out what exactly
that is, where it's coming from.
'Cause if it is something that's been installed
or running for some reason, that could cause
problems in the entire system.
Although it's not something that comes with
the framework.
>>Reto: OK, we have another Hangout question.
>>Joe: Great.
>>Reto: This one is from Matthew.
>>Joe: OK.
Hello Matthew.
>>Reto: I think
you muted Matthew.
>>Joe: Matthew are you muted?
[feedback noises]
>>Joe: Hello?
>>Joe: No?
Yes?
>>Reto: Yeah, if you can unmute yourself.
[feedback noises]
>>Trevor: [laughs]
>>Reto: I don't see on
>>Trevor: Oh wait
>>Matthew: I unmuted it as far as I can tell.
>>Trevor: There you go.
>>Joe: There you go.
>>Matthew: I'm sorry.
I had a question on the smart app update.
Trying to get it to work to see what kind
of impact it has on the application side.
I just updated the Android manifest updated
version, it still downloads the full, you
know, three megs of the app.
I'm using the latest Google Play that I can
see, it's three, 13 dot7 of Google Play.
>>Trevor: Yeah, so there's no one here from
the market team.
So I'm not sure if any of us are gonna know
exactly why that might be happening.
To my knowledge the smart updates are just
supposed to happen automatically.
There's nothing
>>Matthew: [inaudible]
>>Trevor: you need to do as a developer to
take advantage of that.
Um
>>Chet: [inaudible] version of Monarch that
you have right now?
>>Matthew: And then it was, was it gonna impact
the application side at all, 'cause you have
ea signed file that they're somewhat pushing
bytes into it or something.
>>Trevor: No, it shouldn't make a difference
because the signature will get sent along
with it as well.
The updated signature.
>>Matthew: OK.
>>Trevor: Of course, you don't wanna go and
change your signing signature between releases.
>>Matthew: Right, definitely not.
>>Trevor: 'Cause if you do that Google Play
won't accept the update anyway.
And even without smart updates that would
get you in trouble.
So.
>>Matthew: Right.
>>Trevor: So to my knowledge there's really
nothing you have to take advantage of as a
developer.
It's possible that for some reason it's been
temporarily disabled on your phone.
Or there might be some edge case where it
automatically turns itself off.
I'm not sure of the details of how that mechanism
works.
>>Matthew: OK.
>>Trevor: It should just work though.
So, I wouldn't worry about it too much.
>>Romain: And it's the mechanism we use for
our OTS.
We use the same smart updates when we update
the whole system.
And where the system sign in works just fine.
>>Joe: Great.
Hm.
OK.
>>Reto: We have another person on the Hangout.
>>Joe: Wow.
>>Reto: It's very dark where Ismael is, but
I'm gonna put him on anyway.
And, hopefully we'll at least be able to hear
him.
>>Joe: Alright.
>>Reto: Ismael, when you're ready.
[pause]
[feedback sounds]
>>Reto: Um, nope.
>>Joe: [inaudible]
>>Reto: Doesn't sound good.
>>Joe: There is [inaudible]
>>Reto: [laughs] Indeed.
Perhaps we'll go to the next one.
A Moderator question.
>>Trevor: Been eaten by a monster.
>>Reto: Eaten by glue.
Really.
>>Joe: OK.
Next question.
"My developer's console is a bit messy.
And I need to take off the unpublished apps.
Is there any way to do this?"
>>Trevor: So, it depends on what you mean
by unpublished.
If the apps have just been uploaded as drafts
and you're doing, say debugging for license
verification or enact billing, something like
that.
Then there's the delete button.
However, once you published your application,
if you later resend it, if you unpublish your
application later after it's been published,
there is no longer the option to delete an
app and that's by design.
So the reason behind that is because, you
know, there could be purchase history associated
with the app, the package name is permanently
reserved as well, so if you deleted it you
lose the package name.
there's a lot of reasons as to why deleting
a previously published APK or a previously
published application is not allowed.
That being said, there is a UI redesign happening
for Google Play.
For the dev console.
So hopefully that'll go and help clean clutter
up a bit.
But right now, there's not much you can do
to remove those if they've been published.
And if they haven't, you know, check in the
details page and you'll find the delete button
at the bottom.
>>Joe: OK.
Thank you.
This "During this Google IO we heard a lot
about the use of cards.
Is there a standard or best way to try to
use these?"
>>Trevor: Um, is this, I assume this is referring
to the cards in Google Now?
>>Chet: that's the only cards I have.
Those apps specifically.
>>Trevor: So inside of Google Now, there's
you know, the cards are provided by the Google
search app.
So there's really no way to go and create
additional ads.
There's no API for example.
Now, if you wanted to go and try and emulate
the card UI design pattern within your app,
we don't have any published standards on that
yet.
It's still very new.
I'd just try and you know, take a look at
how the app works and emulate it based on
what you see there.
It's not a pattern we're necessarily recommending
to developers yet.
So, yeah, if you decide you know what goes
into your app, you're on the bleeding edge
of things.
>>Romain: And if you want to try to use the
cards as a user, you should go to Google Now.
At the bottom there will be a small button
that says "Show sample cards" if there's no
cards showing.
So you can click on that and Google Now will
generate a bunch of cards so you can get an
idea of what they look like and how you can
talk with them.
>>Trevor: Oh.
Yes.
That.
Yeah.
I didn't think about it from a user point
of view.
If you are a user definitely take a look at
the sample cards.
It'll even tell you some of the ways it gets
triggered.
For example the flight status gets triggered
when you search for a flight.
Most of the time though I found that they
just tend to work properly if you use Google.
>>Joe: Any other comments?
OK.
This is also about Google now.
"Does Google now replace the standard search
app?
And does it search inside third party search
interfaces?
What happens when Jellybean reaches devices
and you press the search button?
Will Google Now start?"
>>Romain: So in the developer preview of Jellybean
that we gave out at the Google IO, you should
go to the settings in Google Now, you can
add initial search sources.
So by default, only some of the built in apps
will be used as sources for searches.
So there will be Google Music, Google Play,
your list of installed apps.
But you can also enable search for other apps
so for instance you search an Evernote, Kindle,
Spotify, that kind of apps.
But you have to go enable them yourself.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Even the little quick search box had that
same requirement.
There was a menu buried somewhere that would
let you go and toggle which apps were indexed.
>>Romain: Yeah.
But they used to be all enabled by default.
>>Trevor: Ah.
Gotcha.
OK.
>>Reto: Got a couple of question in Hangout.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Reto: so I'm going to, think I'm going to
read them out.
There seems to be someone playing music aggressively.
[laughter]
I'll try and sort that out.
In the mean time, Ismael, his question was,
let me see if I can find it here.
"Is it possible to use a USSD code in call
intent?
For example, hash one two two hash."
He's tried to use it in his app but he gets
an error USSD connection problem invalid.
NMI code.
Does that mean anything to anyone.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
So.
The USSD codes are carrier specific codes
to go and do things.
So they have a very odd format.
Now as to why the dialer app isn't accepting
them, it, honestly it sounds like it's either
a bug with the dialer or it's possible that
they might need to be encoded in SIM card
somewhere to be recognized as valid.
But that seems a little off to me.
Without knowing more about the [indistinct]
stack, I can't give you a definitive answer
there.
Yeah, you could go and search through the
source code and see where that error message
is being generated.
I mean it sounds like something that should
work.
>>Joe: Chet?
>>Chet: Nothing.
>>Trevor: Yeah, I mean the [indistinct] stack
is definitely all up there as part of Android
open source.
So you know, take a look through the source
code.
See if you can find where that error is generated.
And that should give you some clues as to
why you're getting the error that you are.
>>Joe: Alright.
Did we have anything else hanging out there,
Reto?
>>Reto: I'm just gonna check to see whether
Simon.
Yeah, Simon does wanna ask it.
So I'm gonna put him on now.
>>Joe: Go ahead.
>>Reto: OK.
You're up Simon.
>>Joe: Hello Simon.
>>Simon: Hello.
[clears throat] Just wanted to ask about STSL
certificate authorities across the [indistinct]
system.
So, across the tel coms, you know, they change.
So mostly what happens is everything happens,
you begin the cell connection and then some
devices just give up because they can't handshake.
And the pattern of the [indistinct] that have
a number of different landing URLs and I just
fail gracefully until you get to a decent
connection.
And the one that seems to fail is Komodo,
mostly, across devices.
So I just wondered what the best approach
was or if you guys recommend it.
A CA to actually assign with.
>>Trevor: so just to make sure, you're not
writing a browser or something big like that.
It's more you could encounter any certificate
actually like access an API endpoint right?
So you do control both the application and
the server?
Correct?
>>Simon: Just making the cell connection to
make sure that most [unintelligible] are in
play.
And it works like 99 percent of the time.
But I do all my work with tel cos.
But eventually one of the tel com releases
a device and it's got some, basically just
removed some stuff from the [indistinct ] list
and burned it onto the device.
And you're left going, oh, I can't make a
connection.
So I know I can't avoid it.
But it's just a case of you guys recommend,
just go with their sign?
Or just or is there a pattern to go for, you
know, a stack, or attempting multiple connections?
'Cause the pattern I go with is just multiple
end points until one works.
And then I stick with it until it keeps working.
>>Trevor: I mean, I'll certainly add, you
probably can't go wrong with their sign.
If somebody shipped a phone without support
for your Verisign, I suspect a lot of websites
would be broken too.
So the same goes for you know, GoDaddy or
Thought, or any of the other really big CAs.
Now, that being said, we do have an API that'll
this is why I was asking if you controlled
both ends.
We have an API that will go and let you register
additional CAs within your application.
So if you know there is a preferred certificate
you'd like to use, you could use that API
call in, say the, explicitly add this to the
trust chain.
>>Simon: OK.
OK.
I'll go looking at that.
I've just been racing by that, not looking.
To be honest.
It didn't handshake so let's move on to the
next one.
But yeah.
OK, I'll go look.
>>Trevor: Yeah, and then since the app is,
I assume it's either preloaded or distributed
through Google Play, correct?
>>Simon: yeah.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
Just as long as the app's coming from a trusted
channel you should be OK there.
The thing you wanna make sure is, you know,
if a user does manage to, if they're side
loading this app for some reason.
Hopefully that's not the case.
But.
Since you are registering additional trust
routes.
If these are just apps from an untrusted source,
an attacker could modify that.
Just make sure that however the user is getting
the APK is from a trusted source and there's
not tampered with
>>Simon: Yeah.
I mean, the other way I did it was to self
sign on both ends and then borrow an encoded
cert onto the app itself.
But it was just too, it wasn't real enough
basically.
And it means that you were permanently in
the state of not really trusting the connection.
>>Trevor: Well, self signed cert isn't bad
as long as the, both ends, both pairs of that
certificate are under your control.
If you control the client, you can use a self-signed
cert. and there's no harm in that.
You're subject to the exact same caveat I
just mentioned that you need to make sure
that the APK is delivered through a trusted
mechanism.
I mean you're only self-signing the cert used
to sign your application.
So.
>>Simon: Well, yeah I just fall into this
kind of crazy elliptical situation with tel
coms where they just say "We gotta go via
some paid for rather than a bunch of dudes."
And that stuff.
>>Trevor: Understandable.
>>Joe: OK.
>>Simon: OK so I dont' feel like I'm doing
anything wrong then by going through multiple
landing URLs to get to a decent site.
>>Trevor: I'm not saying that.
Honestly, you shouldn't have to.
The list of trusted CAs shouldn't change that
dramatically between releases and between
phones.
There is a canonical list of trusted CAs that
is distributed as part of Android Open Source.
And honestly I'd start with that and that
should give you a list of who we say is the
trusted CAs.
And of course there's nothing stopping an
OEM from modifying that list.
But you know, if you go with the common CAs
>>Joe: Yeah.
>>Trevor: If they start taking those out it's
not just going to be your app that fails,
it's going to be the whole web.
>>Simon: Yeah.
I mean, not to keep the whole Hangout on that,
but I, basically
>>Joe: Right.
>>Simon: That's been the case.
You know, your banking would stop working
when they take some out.
But it was basically Komodo got taken out.
Couple devices.
Non-routed.
Regular devices that carriers they shouldn't
just go to [indistinct] to over CAs went missing.
Anyway, that's great.
Thanks so much.
>>Joe: Thank you.
>>Reto: Yeah, we have a couple of quick questions
because we're just about out of time.
>>Joe: OK.
Go ahead.
>>Reto: a couple in the ES room and the Hangout.
So Mario would like to know "Will there be
more templates for activity creation in the
Android developer tools?
And will they support the compatibility library
in order to develop consistent apps for Android
versions prior to ICS?"
>>Xavier: Yes.
Definitely.
Actually the current templates do use the
compatibility library.
But they also use the action bar.
So since we don't have support for the action
bar yet.
I'm looking at you, Trevor.
>>Trevor: Yeah.
[laughs]
>>Xavier: But as soon as we have that then
we'll definitely use the support library and
we are planning on adding a lot more templates,
too.
>>Reto: Excellent.
Thank you.
And.
One more question.
So this is a follow up from Chris Cole who
was asking the portrait to landscape question
earlier.
He says he's writing a note taking app for
Jellybean.
And people keep typing, it scrolls my things
away.
And he's trying to figure out the best way
to initiate the switch to landscape mode for
easier typing.
So I think what Chris is trying to do here
is manually decide whether the user should
be looking at the app in landscape or portrait
mode based on his activities.
Sort of, interaction.
>>Trevor: OK.
So he basically wants to programmatically
switch to landscape.
>>Reto: Yeah.
Or what least he's trying to figure out if
that is the best case scenario.
Which I would probably hasten to say isn't.
Anybody wanna go into more detail?
>>Trevor: So, if I were to, probably the best
way to do this.
Well I was gonna say you could go and tell
layout inflator that you wanna put a landscape
constraint on there.
But then you have the issues like the keyboard
and things like that.
Yeah, I'm not sure how you actually go and
tell the keyboard you want to be in landscape
mode.
>>Romain: You can.
I don't really know the exact API but there
is a way for the app to request a configuration
change.
I don't remember exactly where it is.
Only in the [indistinct ] class somewhere
which can.
Actually a lot of games do that.
They request the, the, landscape rotation.
Now, it might be a little confusing for the
user 'cause you're holding your develops in
portrait and [indistinct ] your [ indistinct
] in landscape.
If the user wants to go in landscape, they
can just turn the device which they will have
to do anyway if you do it for them.
But if they want to stay in portrait then
they can't.
so I think you should let the user decide
what they want and it's less work for you.
So that's probably the best solution.
>>Trevor: I mean, like you said, there are
several apps out there that do do this.
Games, Netflix does it.
But you know, an example of just compare Netflix
and YouTube.
Right.
YouTube, if you're in portrait mode it finds
a way to play the video in portrait.
And I think that's a good model to follow
whenever possible.
>>Joe: I'm familiar with several note taking
apps that are currently available for Android
and none of them force you to go into portrait
or landscape.
You might find that in portrait it's much
more difficult to write your notes.
But certainly if you choose to do that it's
easier than if the application forces you
to go one way or another.
>>Trevor: Yep.
>>Romain: And look what happened with the
launcher on Nexus 7.
It's always in portrait and so the number
one feature request we get is can we get the
launcher to go in landscape as well.
So I think users don't really like it when
you choose the orientation for them.
>>Joe: OK.
I think we have unfortunately run out of time.
I'm really happy that we got so much participation
live from our Hangout.
Thank you very much.
I hope people will stop in again next week.
And until then, we'll all say goodbye.
>>Trevor: Alright, we'll see ya everyone.
[techno music plays]